لكن ده مخرجنا الوحيد عشان كده ن احنا
التسويه دي ميدنا وماشيين
فيها هو ان ان ليل التدخل الخارجي لابد ان
ينجن الموقع الاتفاق الاطاري والاليه
الثلاثيه لان هذا الاتفاق بالاطراف التي
وقعت لا
تستطيع على ما يبدو وصل الى طريق
مسدود الدعم سريع نندمج القوات
المسلحه والله ما نرجع و عشان حنكمل
في مهم جدا قوات الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه
حيكون بيناتهم اجتباك
مستحيل ما تحشد لنا في الخرطوم الخرطوم حق
ناس
كله وديكتاتور ما بنقبل الكلام
ده الحشود العسكريه ماشيه الخلافات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع ترتكز حول المده
الزمنيه
للدمج جماعه كده البلد انتهت مره واحده
والله ما في كلام
ياود انا النبيب المتمرد على قاعده
وه
بتحاربنا ليه يا
برهان
الطريق من الخرطوم الى معبر اشكيت على
الحدود المصريه ال
الا مجموعه تخاز ما معناها الجيش كله
تخاز y